les salariés intermittents travaillant
dans le domaine du nucléaire sont ils
suffisamment protégé la justice devrait
répondre indirectement à cette question
se penchant sur l'histoire de dominick
carrier un ancien électricien atteinte
de leucémie et désormais invalide à 80
il avait travaillé pendant plusieurs
mois dans des sous marins nucléaires
basée près de brest louis carzou et
diane richard l'ont rencontré
le jour où il a appris qu'il allait
prendre ce bateau et travailler sur
l'île longue en juin 96 dominique
querrien s'étaient réjouis car c'était
une promotion électricien de formation
son travail consistait à écrire et les
sous marins nucléaires pendant leurs
périodes de cale sèche en particulier
dans la zone des têtes de missiles
antichars et sur le site qui m'ont dit
certains militaires des militaires nous
ont pas et les initiales comme se sait
que toi t'as pas ce site à personnage
c'est quoi ce si cela ce sont des films
dosimétriques très incertain enfin quoi
je suis pas dangereux besoin je
travaille pas descendre aux
risques et près d'un an plus tard le 7
juillet 97 dominique querrien est
hospitalisée d'urgence il est atteint de
leucémie aiguë or cela fait plusieurs
mois qu'il travaille sans protection ni
contrôle médical sur une zone pourtant
reconnu dès le mois de décembre 96 dans
une note interne de l'île longue comme
une zone à risques en termes de
rayonnement ionisant officiellement
employés par un sous-traitant privé
l'asm nber dominique querrien accumule
ainsi les cdd à répétition
alors aujourd'hui l'inspection
départementale du travail a décidé de
porter plainte contre l'asm n b mais sur
le fond de la sphère les responsables
syndicaux se heurte toujours aussi dense
des militaires et des sous traitants
on a demandé deux choses on a demandé à
rencontrer ceux qui sont responsables
des procédures et on a demandé à visiter
à nous montrer qu'elle était le
dispositif réellement mise en oeuvre
pour garantir aux salariés
qu'ils étaient dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
on n'a pas accédé à notre demande pour
l'instant ni à l'une ni à l'autre ni à
l'une ni à l'autre non non pas du tout
après un an de combat dominique querrien
avait réussi à faire reconnaître le
caractère professionnel de sa maladie
mais plus d'un an et demi après ce
premier avis fait pour le moins
troublant la sécurité sociale
aujourd'hui même de revenir sur cette
décision reste que dominique est
aujourd'hui invalide à 80% interdit
d'exercer un travail avant au mieux août
2001 et bien solitaire dans son combat